now tonight is more than an open it's
Who I am
it's what I know and what I did for over
three decades as a prosecutor Superior
Court judge as well as elected district
attorney the way it works is you are
innocent until proven guilty clear
unambiguous words etched in stone why
would anyone ignore this truth
especially the ranking Democrat on
Senate Judiciary Senator Dianne
Feinstein is stunning but you shouldn't
be surprised the left is committed to
the removal of a duly elected president
the destruction of our system of
capitalism and now and all our assault
on our system of justice to them you are
guilty guilty until proven innocent
but no one in all the years I spent in
courtrooms has ever been able to prove a
negative so forget the time-honored
notions like due process probable cause
beyond a reasonable doubt or a jury of
your peers today unsupported
uncorroborated untested words not facts
are sufficient to convict not just in
the court of public opinion but in the
esteemed hallowed halls of the United
States Senate forget the right to
counsel the ability to defend yourself
the right to confront your accuser or
even cross-examine your a cruise accuser
truth in this scheme is nothing more
than collateral damage if a republican
is on the receiving end of an anonymous
allegation so Dianne let me see if I get
this another Democrat a congresswoman
from California no less for words a july
letter to you containing a completely
unsubstantiated claim that Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh while in high
school
tried to force himself on another high
school student almost 40
I said forty years ago Cavanaugh for
anyone who even cares as categorically
and unequivocally denied the allegation
so why are we just hearing about this
now Diane when you get the letter what
do you do to make sure it's real that
the person is even real given the left's
pension to buy fake dossiers make up
facts and collude with the media to
sabotage even the President of the
United States forgive me if I think it's
all hogwash okay you say quote the
individual strongly requested
confidentiality declined to come forward
or press the matter further and I have
honored that decision Diane you honor
that decision did you even speak to this
alleged person did you meet with her
talk with her interview her
did you ask did you ask her to meet with
others did you ask why she said nothing
for almost 40 years and Diane
why would you wait to even send it to
the FBI is it because nothing in you and
your pack of demon rats that's what I
said
demon rats aka Democrats bag of tricks
was working against Cavanaugh nothing
was working that you were doing
beginning with Kamala Harris Cory Booker
and every onion lewd unhinge lunatic you
could find mr. chairman Brett Kavanaugh
mr. chairman to serve as associate
justice mr. chairman before we proceed
you're out of order I'll proceed we
cannot possibly move forward mr.
chairman there's two daughters mr.
chairman or mr. chairman we revenuers
worry law clubs and documents that we
have everyone else join me tonight and
we believe this hearing should know
those Mexican peas determine time
[Music]
and Diane you've been sitting on this
letter for almost two months
you let Brett Kavanaugh go through days
of Senate hearings meetings with
senators answered then an additional two
hundred and sixty-three pages of 1300
follow-up written questions and now you
want a character assassinate this man
who's undergone six FBI full field
investigations where no such allegation
resembling this anonymous nonsense has
ever surfaced Diane as the ranking
member of the committee interviewing
Cavanaugh how could you possibly let a
moment pass without addressing the issue
and Cavanaugh was right in front of you
and would have had the opportunity to
respond what were you thinking are you
stupid
why would you let it go let me tell you
why you'd let it go Diane because even
you didn't believe it what other reason
could there be now I know about women
who've been sexually assaulted in the
kind of pain they go through it is
different from other crimes it lingers
and rears its head throughout their
lives
I have prosecuted on their behalf for
decades and one of the ways that we
establish their credibility is with how
recent their complaint is a recent
outcry is enormous ly powerful an
anonymous one almost forty years later
not so much Diane but silence I guess I
shouldn't be surprised you bozos in
Congress actually had a fund of
taxpayers money our money to pay
congressional staffers who were victims
of sexual misconduct by your coworkers
it's a fund that even you was a woman a
powerful senator kept quiet about whose
side are you on does it depend on
politics does it depend on the politics
of the accused your audacity
to destroy and try to destroy a man with
impeccable credentials harm his family
and shift the burden of proof to the
accused by alleging one of the most
heinous allegations imaginable shows
your complete disregard for a truth
justice and the American Way and that's
my open